ich denke es ist am besten wenn ich
dieses Video mit einem Statement beginne
und zwar geht es um den Shitstorm aus
dem letzten Jahr es ist nämlich so dass
ich ziemlich voreingenommen an den
sallyi Adventskalender 2022 rangegangen
bin und ich möchte euch versprechen dass
ich dieses Jahr ganz genauso
voreingenommen an den Adventskalender
2023 rangehen werde denn ich liebe Sally
und alles was Sally macht hallo herzlich
willkommen in sallyys Welt und jetzt
testen wir den Sally Adventskalender
2023 auch dieses Jahr ist es eine
richtig fette Box und ich als beste
Freundin von Sally hab natürlich auch
einen Brief
bekommen eine Info möchte ich sofort
weitergeben bevor ich sie vergesse zu
sagen im Video viele Überraschungen sind
sogar extra für den Adventskalender von
mir und meinem Team entwickelt worden
exklusiv und an dieser Stelle möchte ich
sagen dieses Video ist nicht gesponsert
aber ich habe den Adventskalender von
sallyi zugeschickt bekommen wir sind
halt B beste Freunde und das macht man
wenn man beste Freunde ist und jetzt
alle dieses Video ist nicht gespan hat
mir zugeschickt das macht man beste
Freunde wenn beste Freunde
sind und jetzt geht's los Sally und ich
habe eine Sache vergessen die ich jetzt
aufarbeiten möchte ich bekomme ja immer
PR packages also Werbepakete von
Partnern Freunden und deren Produkten
und ich bin super schlecht darin diese
PR Pakete zu posten nicht weil ich die
nicht posten möchte sondern weil ich es
mir immer so vornehme von wegen ich
mache das richtig toll und richtig schön
und dann ich nie deswegen möchte ich
euch noch zwei Sachen von Sally zeigen
vielleicht ist auch schon im Kalender
drin i don't know sally hat ihre
eigenenmischungen rausgebracht
Rotweinkuchen klingt schon mal mega geil
und vanillekpfel Cheesecake sorry aber
was sind das bitte für geile
weihnachtzeitkuchen den hat sie extra
für mich entwickelt weil wir beste
Freunde sind und ein anderes Paket habe
ich vor Monaten von Sally bekommen und
das steht immer bei mir im Badezimmer
und ich will es mal nicht auspacken und
benutzen weil ich mir denke nee nee
erstmal will ich das schön Filmen und
posten dass ich das gekriegt habe Sally
x Annemarie berlind natural beauty das
sind die s s favoritesendlich kann ich
den Inhalt dann benutzen weil ich jetzt
hier gesagt habe Schokolade ist Make-up
für die Seele also ist eine make-upmke
und hier haben wir einmal loose Powder
was ich wirklich
brauche ein Lippenstift einer total
tollen Farbe und ein Mascara und den
packe ich euch doch in die
verlosungsbox und dann gibt aber auch
noch Silikonform für Schokolade und Ruby
Schokolade und superstreusel damit man
sich so eine eigene bunter coole
Schokolade machen kann eigentlich hat
mir superstreusel auch eine Instagram
Nachricht geschrieben dass sie mir ein
Adventskalender zuschicken aber bis
jetzt ist noch keiner
gekommen ich habe letztes mal schon
gesagt dass der kerzenkalender schwer
ist Bo der ist wirklich sehr sehr schwer
der ist anders schwer mir ist eine Sache
direkt aufgefallen hier ist ein Paket
das Start heißt 1 bis 11 und hier ist
die Nummer ein und dann gibt's hier noch
mal 12 bis 24 ich vermute dass man das
vorher aufmacht und dann mit der ein
beginnt guckt euch mal diese Pakete an
ich meine dieser Kalender das ist der
der ist ja schon voll gepackt mit
Paketen da sind ja keine Zwischenräume
oder so guck das mal nee wir sind da
jetzt heute auch ganz kritisch ich bin
ganz kritisch wie teuer war der der ist
sogar noch zu haben da werden dann aber
nicht mehr viele übrig sein der Kalender
kostet dieses Jahr
229 € hat aber einen Warenwert von
380 € ich habe mir dieses Jahr ganz fest
vorgenommen ich werde wieder tolle
Sachen Backen ich bin zwar nicht im
Dezember viel zu Hause und wir haben ja
wegen dem Umzug auch viel zu tun aber
ich muss wieder backen backen ist
einfach gut für die Seele warum schon
wieder backen Alter in Türchen Nummer
Start ist
drin Alter jetzt
mal krank zu jedem Türchen gibt's einen
Brief wir haben einen Brief gekriegt
[Gelächter]
Schwester Nummer ein
okay Nummer ein wie bei Motel amio das
sind einfach so fette Pakete das ist
aber auch so cute dass immer das pinke
sy dann so
vorkommt ja das ist so unfair diese
ganzen Kommentare letztes Jahr Vanessa
Du freust Dich viel zu doll bei sell
Sachen du bist gar nicht richtig
kritisch und sowas ich kann nicht
kritisch sein wenn hallo was für eine
geil ich habe keine Google hupform ich
freue mich gerade so sehr ist das Google
Hupf ja das googleupf ne ja das heißt
Google sally ist einfach dieses Level
von erfolgreich das auf der Google
hupform Sally eingearbeitet ist und sie
diese Google hupform entwickelt hat
danke Sally das ist die schönste
googlehupffor die ich jemals besessen
habe ich werde sie in Ehen halten und
ich habe sofort Bock einen googlehupf zu
backen ich kann dann gleich den
rotweinugle hupfkuchen da reinmachen wie
krass ist das denn zu jedem Türchen
gibt's jetzt so einen Brief der Anfang
liestß sich wirklich wie als ob Sally
dir einen Brief geschrieben hat kribbelt
ist dir nun auch schon in den Fingern
weil du unbedingt einen Kuchen backen
willst ja dann gibt's hier noch ein
Google Hupf Rezept und ein Gutschein bei
ramers Hoven Nummer
2 ich weiß ihr denkt ich tue nur so nein
doch oh mein Gott so ein Ding wollte ich
immer haben nicht nur dass in Nummer Z
so ein mega cooler Puderzucker
besträuber ist die macht auch noch
Puderzucker dazu rein mit einem
googlehupf drauf da kann man gleich sein
googeluben das ist wirklich sehr
praktisch we wenn man so Puderzucker
gerade so auf vanillekirpfel oder sowas
machen möchte oder auf irgendwas anderes
gebackenes habe ich mal so ein grobes
Sieb genommen was immer viel zu grob war
und dann muss ich das mal so reinmachen
dann ist es rüber gekippt und so und
hier machst du einfach und fertig Nummer
3 in Türchen Nummer 3 befindet sich eine
belly also eine bauchtasse woher wusste
s dass ich bauchtassen liebe
wunderschöne Tasse toller großer Griff
tolle Form und natürlich Sally handmade
homeware natürlich s
oh mist ich hab die Briefe dazu
vergessen erstmal ein paar Worte von
unser Königin Sally ich glaub da gibt
jeden Tag ein Rabattcode und Infos über
Puderzucker glaub ich brauche aber nicht
jedes Mal mit aufmachen ne ach wie cool
hier gibt's noch die ganzen anderen
Farben und hier gibt's ein Rabattcode
für
Dieben was soll ich sagen optisch ist
der natürlich auch 10 von ze der
Kalender ich ich komme mir doch auch
schon mittlerweile blöd vor aber ich
finde alles toll an diesem
Adventskalender der ist wirklich
grandios der ist klasse super echt super
guckt euch den doch mal an schaut do mal
wie schön das aussieht guckt hin guckt
hin in der vier eine super coole
Silikonform für Schokolade z.B ich
versuche jetzt ein bisschen weniger
enthusiastisch zu sein oh wow Sally eine
mega coole Silikonform für Schokolade
damit man z.B an Weihnachten seine
eigenen eigene gestaltete Schokolade
verschenken kann oh Sally das ist voll
die coole Idee u toll Nummer 5 ah
natürlich ist auch dieses Jahr wieder
ihre Sha Pflegereihe dabei Lippenpflege
Ros sieht ja toll aus 100% natürliche
Lippenpflege aus ispata Rosen ich
Sparta
Sparta an Nikolaus bekommen wir mal
wieder ein
Riesenpaket jawoh jawohl wenn ich
nächstes Jahr wieder backg Content
machen sollte dann nur mit dieser
Schürze das ist die og Sally Schürze oh
mein Gott wie cool ja dann können wir
mal weitermen ne Nummer s könn mir auch
gut vorstellen wenn das og Sally Hemd
jetzt auch drin wäre dann vielleicht so
ein langer Zopf so als Verlängerung für
den eigenen und dann braucht man nur
noch einen schweäbischen Dialekt und man
sallyi hallo in Nummer 7 natürlich muss
das hier drin sein das Sally
Vanilleextrakt nur echt von Sally ja
toll mein ist nämlich gerade ausgegangen
super vielen Dank Nummer 8 hä ah ist es
dann für die Muffins dass sie so drin
aufbacken können also dass man das so in
die muffinschale legt cool vor allem
wenn man sie darin backt sieh das aus
als ob man so ein Kaffee sich ein Muffin
bestellt hat also bis jetzt muss ich
sagen fast jedes Produkt habe ich noch
nicht Bo habe ich Lust auf Backen jetzt
habe ich Lust Muffins zu machen kommen
wir zu Türchen Nummer ne das beste
Türchen denn neun ist meine
Lieblingszahl und auch wenn ich jetzt
gerade hier die Produkte alle so abfeier
werde ich natürlich ein paar davon in
meine verlosungskiste reinmachen die ihr
jetzt gerade nicht seht weil der sallyi
Adventskalender so groß ist dass der
alles überdeckt und wenn ihr bei dieser
Instagram Verlosung mitmachen wollt dann
folgt mir jetzt auf Instagram dort werde
ich alle Informationen teilen WN es
soweit ist also ich fange ungefähr dem
23 November mit der Verlosung an dann
bekommt ihr das alle mit aber dann folgt
mir doch schon mal auf Instagram das
wäre ganz lieb von Euch und dann packe
ich eigenen Adventskalender und verlose
sie an euch nice und jetzt gucken wir
was in Nummer ne drin ist das ist das
beste Türchen auch gut ja Seife also das
war jetzt bestimmt ein Fehler von Sally
dass Sie hier das nicht zum besten
Türchen gemacht hat oder es ist ein Wink
mit dem zaunfall an mich dass ich mal
Seife benutzen soll raspberry Seife die
Seife riecht krasser als die von Lush
die riecht so ich wollte sie gerade euch
zum riechen geben riecht
mal ja habt ihr gerochen super riecht
doll nach Zitrone oder Olivenölbasis
Nummer
ze komm hör doch auf das ist auch von
Sally sell hat jetzt auch so nebenbei
ein Haselnuss Aufstrich ja nee gar kein
Problem Sally das ist doch super das
gönne ich dir oh mein Gott das riecht
wie jotto ihr hab nicht gesehen dass ich
mE Finger Ring
das schmeckt
köstlich das ist so lecker ich Flip aus
wir machen jetzt weiter mit Türchen
Nummer 11 in Türchen Nummer 11 haben wir
da habt ihr doch gerade das Paket
gesehen Annemarie berland Rose nature
blue light protection Spray
hydratisierend
antioxidativ deutsche Sprache schwere
Sprache
[Musik]
scheiße ich habe vergessen dass ich Rose
nicht
mag ich sag mal so ich packe euch das in
die verlosungsbox ich habe da jetzt zwar
schon zweimal draus gesprüht aber das
ist nicht so schlimm hier sind unsere
Hefte jetzt für 12 bis 24 drin bzw
unsere Briefe und Leute ihr wisst jetzt
was kommt wir haben einen Brief gekriegt
wir haben einen Brief gekriegt dann
haben wir das erste Level geschafft
kommen wir zu Level Nummer
oh Mann ich bin so toll patschig so okay
ja oh ich hatte g was zu essen in Nummer
12 ist ein S Messer drin Kinder seid
ganz vorsichtig mit Messern aber ich
checke nicht genau wofür dieses Messer
gut ist ist das für ganz kleine Brote
gut ganz ganz kleine Brote s muss mir
Nummer 12 erklären mit dem Messer
schneiden wir morgens die Brezeln und
Brötchen vom Bäcker aufstreichen damit
die butterusbrut schneiden Zwiebeln
Tomaten und viele weitere harte und
weiche Zutaten es ist einfach das Messer
was in den meisten Haushälten am
häufigsten verwendet wird gut zu wissen
Nummer 13 ist auch wieder gottlos schwer
natürlich SIS Knusperbrot was soll ich
sagen s Knusperbrot ist das beste Brot
was ihr jemals Essen werdet denn sally
ist ich bin der härteste Kritiker un der
Sonne ja gut aufstellen war nicht so
eine gute Idee 14 was natürlich hat s
ihren eigenen Tee grüner H Busch
Lemongrass Orangenschalen kakaoschalen
Zimtrinde irgendwas Stück gibt's doch
nicht das geht doch
nicht 15 ist auch schon wieder so schwer
boah Sally das ist richtig nervig ne
also dass du so Pakete hast die so voll
schwer sind ah da tut mein Arm voll weh
ah ist das ein scheißkalender AH oh ich
kann das gar nicht ist da jetzt schon
wieder eine hasennusscreme drin oder was
eine Kerze aber was für eine nicht so 0
15 Standard nein wir haben einen
Holzdeckel so eine Kerze ich liebe es
wenn Kerzen diesen Docht haben diesen
holzdoch ja riecht super das ist
Vanille Vanilla forest ja es riecht als
ob jemand vanillepops im Wald gemacht
hab ein Duft aus dem sicon Valley Leute
da ist einfach eine fette Kerze drin
geht's mal weiter mit der 16
backformmesser mit dem backformmesser
löst du Kuchen und Torten ganz einfach
aus Backform herus ohne diese zu
beschädigen ja das ist auch so ein
Produkt das cool das ist so ein Produkt
viele können vielleicht damit nichts
anfangen aber die Leute die oft Backen
schau an alle die immer die
Geburtstagstorten für alle machen und
irgendwie fürs Wochenende und so die
appreciaten
das boah wenn das timo ist und der sich
kein Schlüssel mitgenommen hat Gnade ihm
Gott Gnade dir Gott kann das sein dass
du unten mit deinem Schlüssel aufgemacht
hast und oben einfach an der Tür grüß
werden
wolltest ich glaub nicht ja jetzt bin
ich komplett raus aus dem Konzept ah
kuchenmesser okay next one
SEV natürlich natürlich klar gibt's eine
Flasche von ihrem eigenen Olivenöl h ich
verstehe die Frage nicht frühernte kalt
gepresst so mag ich mein Olivenöl am
liebsten was soll ich euch sagen
Olivenöl Nummer 18 den Witz machen wir
jetzt aber nicht mehr weiter wir kommen
jetzt einfach mal darauf klar dass
einfach alles hat okay ich kann es nicht
ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen
brauche ich finde ich fantastisch ich
habe so ein Ding aus Holz und ich kann
Timo noch so oft sagen bitte packst
nicht in die Spülmaschine er hält sich
nicht dran und mein aus Holz sieht
genauso aus nur halt richtig vergammelt
und aus Holz Timo guck mal kannst du
gleich in die Küche
bringen ein Kochlöffel aus Silikon sag
Danke Sally danke s Nummer
19 ich habe gesagt ich werde nichts mehr
dazu sagen und dabei bleibt es auch
gartenkräutersalz sys Gewürzmischung mit
Steinsalz fantastisch wir sind in den
20ern
angekommen was ist das ich würde jetzt
sagen das ist so zum sauber machen
putzen macht mich glücklich wir haben
jetzt ein universalschaber oh DAV haben
wir doch
1000ende wir haben doch kein Schaber das
ist zum das hab zum Dreck wegkratzen dii
Stück haben wir nich doch klar reagiert
doch nicht so mein Gott das für ein
Video das haben wir do schon sag toll
toll das habe ich ja noch ich noch nie
gesehen danke was für eine coole Form
und die Größe ist auch perfekt liegt
wahrscheinlich richtig gut in der Hand
sieht man von hier aus ja das liegt
richtig gut in der Hand alle möglichen
Sachen wegschaben DAH der Name
universalschaber danke 21 handhygienpray
das ist ein klassischer lagerlehmacher
oder da muss das das muss aus dem Lager
raus es riecht sehr gut es riecht sehr
perfümiert
oh
handhygienpray und dann steht da unten
ode Colon Check nicht was ode Colon
heißt ich dachte das heißt also dass es
ein Parfüm ist ich erinnere mich noch
gut daran dass handwasser in unserem
Haushalt immer verwendet wurde wenn
Gäste kam das handwasser türkisch
cololonia wurde als Begrüßung bei den
Gästen verteilt noch dazu gab es ein
Bonbon kommt Leute spuch auf die Hand
ihr seid hier meine Gäste
und jetzt Patsche Hand raus kleiner Witz
am
Rande jetzt rie Hal wieder nach Rose ich
bin jetzt nicht der größte rosenfan und
jeder der jetzt durch meine Tür kommt
wird erstmal so angesprüht 22 ist es
etwa ein
og Sally Küchentuch das ist genauso wie
man möchte dass ein Küchentuch ist du
hast das Gefühl das saugt dir 100 l
Wasser auf vorletztes Türchen Türchen
Nummer 23
30 € Gutschein für den Shop den gebe ich
euch nicht den behalte ich selbst ich
habe ja bald auch eine neue Küche und so
das muss ich auch ausstatten und alleine
puderzuckerstreuer reicht da nicht jetzt
komm4 das ist so schwer Tür num 24 es
ist
Heiligabend und wir gehen ganz happy zu
unserem si Adventskalender und machen
das 24 Türchen auf oh ich sehe schon
einen kleinen gusseisernenck was ist das
ich lüge euch nicht an ich habe mir das
schon immer gewünscht oh mein Gott guckt
mal wie cool die ist bei sowas mache ich
keinen Spaß da könnt ihr mir glauben ich
wollte die ganze Zeit schon so eine te
die ist genauso wie ich die haben möchte
also ein Teesieb das macht man dann hier
rein bum zack Tee rein heißes Wasser
Deckel zu nirgendo S drauf ach doch ob
auf dem Deckel natürlich klar wow die
ist cool ich bin ich bin ich kann ich
mir fällt nicht mal ein lustiger Witz
irgendwie ein oder irgendwas ha echt
wirklich vielen Dank Sally dass ich das
so von euch bekommen habe ohne dass ich
irgendwie danach fragen musste oder
sonst was ich fühle mich richtig geehrt
dass ich eure beste Freundin bin und das
hat auch noch mal richtig
gezeigt also 229 kostet dieser Kalender
ja ich kann gar nicht also was man alles
dafür bekommt ist gestört 380 €
Warenwert stand da ja schon dieser
Kalender ist ich finde diesen Kalender
so gut gemacht und wenn man Sally Fan
ist und Fan von den Produkten ist dann
ist das so geil der ist auf gar keinen
Fall günstig also 229 € muss man erstmal
rausholen aber das kann man ja z.B dann
als Weihnachtsgeschenk machen man
schenkt z.B einfach der Mama oder der
Freundin also jemand der großer Sally
Fan ist das zum 1 dezember und dann ist
das Weihnachtsgeschenk ja auch schon
quasi mit drin und das ist dann der
Kalender ich glaube so hatten wir das
mal mit himos Schwester gemacht da haben
wir ihren Adventskalender einfach als
Weihnachtsgeschenk gemacht und dann
hatte sie den Adventskalender als
Weihnachtsgeschenk so und das war's mit
dem Video ich bin mega happy mir ist es
scheißegal falls jemand denkt dass ich
zu vor eingenommen an diesen Kalender
rangegangen bin wirklich das ist so ein
geiler Kalender ich fand den
kerzenkalender das letzte Mal schon cool
und der hat 150 gekostet wenn ich jetzt
sehe was ich hier für 229 € bekomme es
ist geisteskrank ich bin so happy und
wir sehen uns dann was nächste Mal
wieder